[Musique]
ça va plutôt bien là je viens d'arriver
il est enfin je suis arrivé hier soir
après un premier cycle
on a besoin de disposer un peu plus de
réfléchir de savoir quels sont vos
prochains objectifs si on veut repartir
ou pas et il ya des moments un peu plus
dur est donc ça fait du bien de revenir
pour ça la spa enfin la vie d'une sport
d'un sportif ou une sportive de haut
niveau
c'est compliqué parce qu'on rencontre
des choses difficiles des choix
difficiles à faire et la blessure elle
en fait partie
donc la blessure c'est quelque chose
d'important et à prendre en compte
il faut faire attention faut savoir au
plus vite la l'éliminer la guérir et il
ya des fois le corps répond en accord
avec ça
[Musique]
non
ça leur fait pas tout le monde je pense
je pense que ça fait du bien à tout le
monde et surtout à ma parce que je suis
venu aussi pour ça mais je pense qu'eux
aussi sont contents que je sois là et et
les petites ça leur fait du bien de voir
bas dans ce gymnase parce que on parle
souvent de moi mais c'est vrai que je
suis pas je suis pas là souvent quoi
[Musique]
département m'a beaucoup aidé là dessus
parce que il m'a permis de de partir de
revenir sur lille pour me ressourcer
quand j'en avais besoin parce que je
sais que si je n'avais pas eu ça je
serais pas peut-être serait peut-être
pas arrivé là où je suis maintenant et
tu vas besoin de toutes ses primes
parce que la gym ou le sport c'est un
coup et on a besoin d'eux d'être aidés
comme ça pour pour bouger pour pour les
compétitions pour être récompensé parce
qu'on a on a du matériel à acheter pour
la gym et ça c'est important ça ça
permet de l'arrivée là où on veut aller
l'année olympique ça se résume en
compétition aux pétitions sur
compétition et préparation sur
préparation c'est tout le monde tout le
temps à fond et voilà pour les je crois
pas parce qu'on vit plein de choses on
rencontre plein de personnes on voyage
beaucoup et et ont créé des liens avec
des personnes
on rencontre le monde du sportif et le
rêve des jeux on le réalise
j'ai envie de repartir parce que c'est
quelque chose que j'ai envie de revivre
et voilà je vais me donner tous les
moyens pour partir sur sur la même chose
voire mieux
[Musique]